I
'm doing Bach Hahahahaha Well, it's time to
cut the ball, or
rather, I'm actually like that, but I don't want to
get
9000. Yeah, yeah, yeah.  Earnings and so on I thought I
knew the face of most of the groomers, but
maybe I won't be impregnated in 4th place.
I don't get it, I'm picking on girls right now, but
I don't have many chances to get close to girls because I've been hit with
a
bounty.  Wait a minute, Chateau-chan, I
told you not to use the sensitivity code, right
?  I
'm Karl, the former president of Hamayaku.
I've never seen anything like this before
Chateauxun This month is amazing! I've
secured a star in Reny prefecture alone.
It's too much The
mafia has put a large amount of reward money on the sanctioned person,
and the business operators who make a living from it are making a big move, but
even the politicians and the police are doing
this.  It's a
shame to live in a different house
.